What up you virgins (we are only 9 so that's true). That's right
It's me. Back at it again with another girlfriend simulator
to show you guys how it's done
How you respect wahmen in a way that--
everyone (gets too lazy to talk about that)
Okay, let's go everybody. I'm in, okay.
heyy. oh wow you
*poods trynna talk chinese*
Get the darts on the table and aim the darts board to target
Finally, I have a whamen I can play darts with.
Hey, excuse me.
Hey, Hello, Ow
*super jumps*
Jesus!
Oh okay, I can walk wherever I want. I see.
SURPRISE!
AHHHH  *nightmares for the 9yos*
Oh my God. Jesus! *he's scared of his own surprise*
Excuse me you do that again. Oh my god. Oh my god never again.
Whoa! Look at the view. We're like super rich and stuff
Can you be quiet please? I'm trying to figure out the controls. Okay, this is
SUPER AnNoYIng
You're watching anime. What are you fckin (family friendly) loser? Hey, listen to me.
I just realize last video got demonetised. So really why..
am I doing this?
No, I'm too tall. I'm too tall for this game. Alright, what if I
I lost my hand, everybody. My hand is gone forever. (that is so sad rip)
Can't-- I can't reach-- I can't reach them
So how do I make myself shorter? I'm too freaking tall!!!
What is this?
I can't!
(that is so sad rip felix height)
How do I make myself short?
You be quiet for the love of God. Oh, okay. I got it. What if I squat, and then I reset the height?
Oh my god, I'm a genius. Alright, then. I reset the height. Now this is my new height. Look, I'm a giant
I am God amongst the whamen. Fear me tiny one. Oh
Uhh. Ha ha. I might as well pick these up with my feet ha
GoD DaMNiT
Shut it!! oWW
I can't do it. I'm too tall. I'm too tall for this world *stares*
Screw-- I'm out. I'm out *dashes away to fridge*
How tall am I supposed to be?
Please! *trynna grab the darts*
I can't physically get any lower
*the struggle is real*
Yes! I glitched it.
YoU'Re GoNNa DiE NoW
*epic music on*
*chinese*
*pewds stab respects* Pa Pa Pa Pa Pa
Pa Pa Pa Pa Pa Pa Pa
(rip)
A'ight, here we go.
No
*chinese*
*struggling to get the precious sharp blades*
Where it go. Where it go. Catch it.
No
*hand moving on its own; this is a horror*
*felix laughs*
Shut up
Got it. Okay. Got it. Now. I gotta beat her.
OwWWwW
God, damn it (rip precious sharp blades)
*chinese*
*replays felix hittin the wall*
God damn it.
Yes. No, do I have it? I think I have it
Yes, I got it, okay, all right
now...
*chinese*
*moans oof*
I got zero points. I spent 30 minutes
Getting zero points. All right. What do you got, show me what you got. A rebate you can't even hit anything.
You schmu-
ZeRooO ZErooOo *walmaaart in bg*
ZEROO!
You're nothing you worthless
ZERO!
throw it
YAY *Pew lost empowerment
F*** u  (felix jealous cause he can't aim)
*Rage Scream*
ROAR
*bums akward to wall
Whatever. Whatever, I bet you can't
Hey, honestly, that's-- that was pretty good. Great. I gotta play again. I gotta do it again. I gotta do it again
I just got to do it again. I just got to do it again. Just got to do it again *depressed*
You just got to do it again Felix. You just got to do it again. Yeah, yeah
Yeah, I don't mind doing that it -- what the heck are you T posing about?
No
*felix standin like a real whamen respecter that can't shoot a dart*
*rip*
*quality sound*
I have to beat her 3 times. I have to beat her 3 times, I have to-- oh my god, no
Oh, I'm even taller now. There has to be a way around this. Oh, I honestly feel nothing
But hate. I can't go below the floor. I just can't
What if I place my sensors higher up? Would that make a difference.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god (yes it did)
Oh my god, I got it. BAaAHh
Shut up what it is i--- *rage*
Are you kidding me?
*chinese*
They don't go in. I swear to God I swear to God they don't go
They don't go where I want them to go. They don't go where I want them to go
aight
Yes. That's a real man does it-- that's how a real man does it
SHaAAaAAAAAa
aight watch this
HOW IN THE??
*chinese*
All right, I'm bending the rules I don't care I don't care
ZEROO! (wdym it was a 3!?)
ZERO-
*HORROR*
OH GOD
Yes, and I won. Fair and square you schmuck. Two more
(FELIX is now neck on neck with Chinese-chan how will this end??)
YAY
ZEROO!!
Get one more chance
*Watch pewds making points fare and square
yep
*continues fareplay
I'm just that good. I'm just that--
I don't care no bye
Min chila le shut your mouth. Okay, stop crying. There we go. Oh my god. Is that a gun?
Is that a gun I get to-- haa yes
Why am I so tiny now?
noo
i'm too short *cries; rip felix height again*
it's not fair
Okay, all right, I'm tall -- what up
*metal gear solid alert sound* Oh, that's sorry
what we're playing a vr game together
*girl enjoys being threatened*
Beat her two times. Okay, you're going down
mei
*Star wars shooting over her*
*summoning acient spell
How is she not dying?
Begone THOTT (oof that word)
*more professional gunslinging*
*LEVEL UP*
(NOW HES CASTING THE SPELL)
(NANI!? HE disappeared!?)
*clicking sounds*
BAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
BAAAAAA!!!!
DIE!!!
*silence*
DIEFA!!! ???
*violence*
What's next?
Are you fking kidding me? Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? I did not lose. I did not even get hit
Alright she's dead now--she's dead. Where are ya SHOW YOURSELF
i had enough!
BAAAAGH!
*EPIC MUSIC*
*silence*
*Le epic scene continues
YASS yes
*The PewDiePie rawr*
*violent eyes*
hooahhh
That's right, that's right you ever face me again - i aint gonna shoot ya
Thot
finally
*zooms oof*
Yaaas
*Chinese*
i won
*chinese*
there you go
There you go
hope you enjoy that
*more chinese*
*sits in 399 chair*
Are we done here?
*more n more chinese*
okay good
ok
*nonstop chinese*
please stay away from me and this video being demonetised
Ah, this is just getting weird
*rock paper scissors in chinese*
Please have a seat have a seat. I'm Chris Hansen. Yeah, and I want to ask you some questions. Please have a seat
i won
*how to cancel out kisses as a pro*
*laughs*
Alright last one then we beat this game
YaaS
Help Mei find the red. Oh my god. Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me?
how
*all day chinese*
*chinese chinese*
I don't know and I don't care
What if she
i dont see it
Are you finding it? Maybe try over there. *laziness*
does the clock work?
*realizes he can pull of books* oh i can!! woah
All right, I'll find it  I'll find it for my queen.
I will find it. I will find it for my queen
Where is it?
*silence*
I hope I'm not making too much of a mess
I FOUND IT
I FOUND ETTTTT
I CANTT--
*thuds. AHHH
It's right there!!!
I FOUND IT (she cant hear u)
Grab it, please please, please please please
PLEASSEEEE
YASS YASS *victory royale*
*unmanly laugh*
I finished the game. I finished the game
daddy needs a hug
Gimme me a hug.
Oh you just gonna go?
You
*RAGES of failure*
(hugs for whamen respecter felix)
No hug for me
I'm sorry? No hug for me. Hey won't you have a seat right over there? Oh no
That was together VR
And oh my god, was it fantastic?
Leave a like if you enjoyed. Buy the merch because I will get demonetized
Don't spill G fuel on it because it will get. It's designed by me. It's very nice merch it's selling like a
Walmart everybody and I'll see you guys next time
bye bye
*Subs to ChadIsMyName* <<sub to him he said, cool bus driver
subtitles by nightfighter4 <<great guy, sub if you want, he thanks bus drivers
edits by haise sasaki <<infinite weeb
And last but not least: Sub to pewsipei, turn on notifs, smash like 25 times or i smash ur walmart, 9 yo fist for ya 👊(sub to Flindler)